we're gonna talk about some I'm gonna
talk about some stuff that's you know
very fresh off the press for SRL very
kind of unprecedented the past six
months that have sort of you know wound
up in us having our foot in the door of
the art world after 39 years and talk a
little bit you know a little bit about a
little bit about some historical things
about srl for the benefit of those who
just don't know anything about it
because as I always like to say we're
very widely unknown and so what I'm
going to do is just in the background
I'm going to pull a play just sort of a
selection of clips from shows and now I
got to turn the sound down here
[Music]
so so how I came to be here and to be
doing the things you see behind me
beginning back in 1978 was basically a
process where I was in high school and I
was a very politically active person in
high school and I was very interested in
technology and I was taking courses
mathematics courses and you know really
kind of preparing myself basically I saw
myself as kind of a scientist I think
but at a certain point I became you know
I came to realize partly because of you
know anti-war stuff I was doing and
there was a very there was a very big
technology company that was really
pretty much very mainly involved in what
military war production electronics
called EMR in town and so I was involved
I was involved I knew about them because
I was I happen to have a mimeograph
machine and the people at the local
college found out I had a mimeograph
machine and so I started printing up
anti-war stuff that we were distributed
in the high school and so I you know I
became a you know I was very aware of
like you know I somehow it crossed my
mind that okay if I want to prepare
myself to be a full-on scientist
basically what I'm faced with is this
wall of war
you know warfare or something you know
commerce at least you know and was like
do I really want to go there and so I
changed course in high school and I went
into sort of more of a blue-collar
worker
kind of thing where I learned how to do
took a machine shop course which I ended
up teaching because the pros the the the
teacher didn't know anything about
anything about machines or manufacturing
anything like that so I got my foot in
the door with sort of manufacturing
engineering there I realized I liked the
tools I got out of high school and I was
like you know what I'm gonna like and
that by then I kind of decided I kind of
was interested in the arts and
interested in moving in that direction
but I was like all the artists I knew
were just sort of like meager money
meager kind of beggar bums and I was
like you know I don't want to live
hand-to-mouth when are you gonna get
time to work right you gotta have money
right to do anything so so I I went and
learned yeah I went and I worked I ended
up with all these jobs because I guess I
was pretty good at that stuff you know
one job I did which was a very
educational position whereas I worked
for a big machine shop in northern
Florida when I was 18 and the first
thing they asked me to go do you read
blueprints Esther you had to taught
myself how to read blueprints I think is
what can you read these blueprints and
he walked me back to the back and he
showed me his blueprints from the Air
Force that were like 8 feet wide and I
was like yeah you know I said this is
the call-out for this and I went through
all the call-outs on this huge page and
he goes well do you know what these
things are and I said no and he goes
these are target robots for the f-111s
he goes we have to make like a few of
these things and goes I said well how
big are they he goes well look at them
and I looked I flipped through the
drawings we he had to help me flip
through because the pages were huge they
were 30 ton robots that ran on railroad
tracks and he goes he goes this were
gonna be making and you're gonna be the
first guy on this project so I started
doing it and you know I was good enough
where after a couple weeks they said
you're the foreman on the job and I was
like 18 and so then they hired these
other guys who are like 40 and 50 to
work under me so I did that for like
almost a year you know I learned a lot
about manufacturing engineering you know
working with these huge tools and it was
a big place giant machine tools and
stuff and they would just say yeah you
know how to run a lay just go run that
12 foot long lathe and you know so from
start to finish I built one and a half
of these and then had to go back to you
know and then I went out and you know it
had to go back to my hometown and then
ended up moving out to California worked
in the oil fields welding high-pressure
pipes and you know so I was I was
exposed to a lot of really intense heavy
industrial critical type of operations
and then I went to art school for four
years and I learned about the wonders of
not working for a living and just the
wonders of not doing anything practical
and I didn't really do you know any you
know I did
I kind of had a lot of crazy ideas that
you know but mostly it was I did mostly
traditional art so if I got a degree in
visual arts but there was a you know
there was a very big kind of a punk rock
scene going at my school this is in the
late 70s and a bunch of the people went
to New York and they were in bands and
stuff but I ended up going out to San
Francisco I didn't really know why but I
ended up going out there and shortly I
just I realized you know San Francisco
was undergoing the bear was undergoing
this transformation to a sort of a an
industrialized economy to a high tech
economy and so what that meant was that
there were all these places that were
previously industrial facilities that
were literally abandoned I don't Fenny
buddy remember San Francisco but like
for instance where Costco is in San
Francisco is where a huge brewery was
and so they were there were all these
places and I just you know being an
adventurous and curious young man I
started just going into them and I
realized that they were just open and
there was like factories inside like
complete factories with like all this
production equipment I was like holy
crap you know and I started collecting
that stuff I started thinking about
collecting it and then I just said wait
a minute
and I just came up with the idea of
doing survival research labs I came up
with the idea repurposing industrial
military equipment and creating machines
that had no practical value or use but
that were formed from things that did
have use value and to create them and to
prove that they worked basically like
experiments that would prove that they
that they functioned and they would be
shows public shows and so I just in 1978
I just started I had a purpose because
to me it was like you know I realized
that to to even to get there at all and
and I had been exposed to that when I
was a kid at these production facilities
but I just didn't buy the story because
the story was you've got to have you're
doing this because it's like benefitting
the military and that's important to the
country and like this is like going to
make it so the f-111 jets can
go down do strafing moves on robots and
it's all you know they're gonna go kill
people in Vietnam and we're gonna win
and and then I worked at other places
the oil places we need this for the
economy to make money and I was like but
what about the beaches and Isla Vista
where I'm living which are destroyed
from oil wait a minute you know I just
never believed the story and so I decide
but I decided that the structure was
important the tools were important the
technology was important and the
structure was important so the first
thing I had to do was create a reason to
do it so I created srl is the reason to
do it and then I created a structure to
do it which was to create srl as a
company because I realized companies are
the ones that get away with everything
but way before 37 years before Citizens
United
I said aha if I ever want to like
destroy like cities and destroy people's
lives or you know do anything powerful
you know no matter what it is I have to
be a company to get away with it to
actually just to do it so I created a
structure and then you know and then I
got a warehouse so there was a place to
do it in and so you know I started off
as a company I started doing these shows
and lo and behold how most immediately
scientists were attracted to srl and
started coming to the you know not not
artists you know not like there were
artists that were interested but full-on
scientists from places like Stanford
started coming and saying we want to
work with you we want to help you out
and so in fact the first important
science advisor that was at SRO was Phil
Paul who was from Stanford he was
getting his doctor here in sensor
technology mostly dealing with laser
sensors and stuff and so he goes yeah I
can help you build lasers I can help you
at all so we started off you know that
was in 78 or 70-79 you know which was at
the time you know building a 50 watt co2
laser was fairly high tech you know and
so but he he was instrumental in all
kinds of things like helping us in like
helping us with electronics because you
couldn't buy anything off-the-shelf back
then in turn
robotics helping us with you know
helping us with you know plcs for
controlling robot you know simple robots
you know simple sequencers for that and
and and then that the fact that we were
actually creating these working devices
using what at the time was a fairly high
technology that then attracted other
people who were really back in the early
night or late 80s and early 90s and so
then we you know we were you know all
these machines you know it's always been
pretty much about presentation value you
know we're not we're not out there
trying to reinvent anything practical
even do anything practical it's just all
about creating machines that can tell
some kind of a strange story you know in
different locations you know around the
world and you know I think we you know I
think it's generally recognized that we
succeeded in doing that and so you know
what's gone through a lot of iterations
over the years that's uh here we go
that's me that was me challenging mark
raybert because he's he built that
Boston Dynamics robot that threw a
cinder block and so right afterwards
I threw a cinder block further with the
spine robot and so he was using that in
presentations that video and
presentations like at Boeing in the
weapons research lab down there making
talking about how we were making parody
videos of his videos but I've never been
able to talk him into using one of his
machines at our shows unfortunately but
so so all these years for 38 years
all my artist friends go oh my god you
know you're gonna be all these museums
you're gonna be in galleries you know
all this stuff's gonna happen I was like
you know what it's never gonna happen I
just knew it I didn't really know why
but as the years went on and we are our
engagement with the art world
was always sort of peripheral even
though they were you know like we did
the groundbreaking for the San Francisco
Museum Modern Art and then the Museum of
Modern Art promptly removed us from
their history and tried to sue me after
that so you know that's been kind of the
nature of the relation
ship its I wouldn't say love-hate
because hates a very strong word you
know love I love the fact that these
people provide fronts for me to do these
events because it's hard hard to get
permission for them we do get you know
these are permitted events but you know
we're living a very permissive part of
the world in California so it's easy to
get a start once you get a start you can
talk people into doing these things
other places but but the art well no
it's not that I rely you know I've
always I've always had my theories about
why there was never and then no one said
let's do a big show at a museum and
stuff so a year about a year ago we got
the call I think through my wife hear
the call from Marlborough gallery and
they said we want to do like we want to
do something with you like in a real
blue-chip means you know gallery setting
I'm like okay I said that sounds great
you know so went to New York you know
we're in the era so we went to
Marlborough and madame and they seemed
really nice and you know I don't I don't
have any basis to trust them and not
trust them they seemed they talked a
good talk a couple months later that you
know year you know year later like in
the in the last summer they said let's
really do this we've got a slot open in
January we want to do like a big
production with like tons of machines
we're gonna fill this seven five or
seven thousand square-foot gallery right
in the Chelsea and I'm like wow you know
these guys are we're gonna give you
production money to help pay for it I'm
like wow these guys are serious
you know they transferred the money and
so we were on and so we ended up you
know the the goal with srl is to always
take these technologies and really
squeeze every last little bit of power
and intensity out of them in a these
presentations short of injuring people
or killing us when we're I mean the real
danger is when you're working on the
stuff it's far more dangerous building
big machines and it is actually staging
them because there's there's there's
more control
it's a more of a controlled setting
being in a big factory is very dangerous
people get hurt in factories we have a
very good safety record with that way a
perfect safety right except for me but
I'm the example that everyone stays safe
by because I can just say look what
happens if you are careless for like one
instant you're either dead or you're
you're impaired you know for the rest of
your long life so so anyway so we did
this show and so I wanted to get that
same feeling of intensity that same
threat level you know that we that that
that technology you know pushed into
like a powerful mechanism can can can
impress on people and so we're in a
gallery in Chelsea in Manhattan I'm like
okay what are we gonna do you know so
the idea was to to just do you know I
just said let's just keep it simple
what would a physicists say a physicists
would say you have to release as much
energy in the shortest period of time as
possible and I'm like okay that's it and
but you have to you have to you've got
to you've got to stop it and so that has
how the title of the show came about
I've got to get to the I'm gonna show a
little video of the beginning of this
show if I can figure out how to get out
of here okay here we go so this is a
short video so this is the title so it's
kind of topical you know like
inconsiderate fantasies of negative
acceleration characterized by sacrifices
of a non-consensual nature because
there's a lot of talk about
non-consensual Nastase you know and and
also you know here also let me get this
up again it was 20 below zero the chill
factor here so we're so first we you
know we ran stuff outside but like to
really get the feeling of intensity that
an SRL live show can
give I said what we'll do is we'll just
take the pitching machine which is the
most dangerous thing we have it's a it's
a big it's got a 400 and 500 cubic inch
Eldorado motor and it basically shoots
six foot two by fours at 200 miles an
hour
it's a machine gun for six foot two by
fours it shoots two per second which is
20,000 joules of energy if you stop it
suddenly and so that's almost as much
that's more than a 50 caliber machine
gun bullet so I was like okay that's the
key the key is is his energy dissipation
and so we built a box Johnny over there
spent a lot of hours well we built a
bulletproof plastic box with half-inch
lexan that would handle 20,000 joules of
energy immediately stop and that was the
inconsiderate fantasy of negative
acceleration which I also felt was very
you know okay I try to get a little
political jabs and every now and then so
it just seemed like as a society we're
kind of going backwards so I thought
well you know let's just talk about the
negative acceleration it's you know it's
it seems like an important theme so so
we what we did is we built this Cuban
right there in the gallery you know
because we had an exhaust extraction
system to extract all that fumes from
the 500 cubic inch engine we were able
to fire two hundred two by fours with
people standing six inches away and
every time it hit that you know of
course it was like a giant speaker so
there was like half inch plate with ribs
in the back to break it apart so so that
was that was sort of the centerpiece of
this gallery exhibition so we did this
we did this outside let me see if I
could yeah so this is outside in 20
below zero that the gallery just said
will just block the street off where
city shut the street down for two hours
in
have nobody said a word to us and so we
just ran a few machines down the street
little love grabbing there and shaking
between machines so this machine on the
left is the spine robot
this is that disease right there
and when that hits the water freakin
whoa so another safety first machine
there the rotary jaws that can actually
bite a 2x4 and a half because of the
kinematics of it you see all these you
know typical art looking people there
and you can see it's all sealed off it
has it you know it's a little bit of
design stuff but it we really know this
isn't about bored 160 there
it doesn't quite convey the experience
of it and this is this is like a
computer computer-controlled walking
machine it's about this little bit
bigger than an elephant and it just has
a simple PLC we rebuilt that for this
now here we have a our practical use for
a fanuc robot which is to take a 55 inch
screen and keep rotating it to make it
really moving it around to make it
really hard to watch eight hours of our
videos so so anyway so so we did this
show and the gallery was like you know
sending us sending it for it at first
they were just sending me pictures like
god this place is really crowded like
there's all these people in here like
everyday like and they send me pictures
showing that it was like packed with
people and I was like huh okay and then
after about two weeks of that they just
said there's just millions of people
they didn't even bother sending photos
anymore and you know the gallery you
know it's a the galleries a hundred and
twenty years old from London I mean
Marlborough goes back generations the
people that run the gallery have been
running the gallery for generations so
it's old like you know it's old gallery
stuff and so you know at the end they
were just like wow you know it's just
like there's we've never had any show
ever in our history that had this many
people and I was like yeah that's what
it takes you know that's what happens
when you know people people are excited
to see technology in a you know because
frankly here's the here's here's my
theory about why it here's my theory I
have a general theory of possibility
general theory of art in the technical
world like everyone talks about how
artists no no the the people in the tech
world don't collect art you know and my
theory especially after this show my
theory is that you know what what it is
is like people who work at tech
companies people who run tech companies
they don't want to sit around and talk
to artists they wanna they all they add
think about in their lives is tech stuff
they want to talk about the latest
gossips of Silicon Valley they want to
talk about something they read about
like oh this cool thing robotics you
know or there's this sensor here this is
going on here
they want to talk about they don't want
to hang around artists like back in the
East Coast where the art scene really is
it's like you know the rich people that
pay for the stuff that invests in arts
they want to hang around artists because
it's a cool hip thing and the fact you
know if an artist is technically
involved directly in the manufacture of
something technical then it's just like
gross it's like the maid right it's like
I don't want to talk to like someone who
does anything real you know so you'll
find as I found all the way from back in
the 80s and my friends in you know who
were like up in the art world like you
know Kenny Scharf or Keith Haring or you
know those were friends of mine back in
the 80s and in New York I would go to
their places that would be like a
factory it was all that Andy Warhol
factory motif where they wouldn't do
they would do a sketch and like 20
people would build all this stuff for
him they didn't you know and so fast
forward ahead to like tech art and
you've got people most of the people
like you know someone like okay I'm
gonna use an example that I used in the
New York Times I think like Jordan
Wolfson who did these really advanced
robotics kinematic sculptures of like a
stripper robot dancing in front of a
mirror okay and so he didn't do any of
that he just found someone who's a
friend of mine who does like who does
like special effects in LA and that guy
built the whole thing for him for a
million dollars but that guy didn't but
he didn't know anything he didn't know
anything but he just said I want this
robot that does this will kind of make
it dirty looking and and have like a
voice on it or something like that he
just kind of he was the director of it
you know and that traditionally is the
role of artists in art and technology
type of events and I find that revolting
because I believe that to be doing this
stuff and if you're going to be if
you're gonna be telling a story with
technology that's outside of the range
of the practical or the productive you
really have to have sweat equity in it
you know I really believe that's
important of course I would believe
that's important because I do spend so
much of my time actually physically
making the stuff that is in the
so you know I think that's important and
you know when we did this show it agreed
to this show at Marlborough I set out to
try to make that point and to try to you
know to see if we could convince anybody
to step up the plate by anything and
Marlborough totally pushed it they had
all these meetings and in the end I'm
not going to tell you who it is but the
CEO of a very large tech company goes
okay I've got to have I've just got to
have an SRL machine in my corporate
Lobby and I'm willing to do whatever I
need to do to make it happen so he came
to visit me I gave him a proposal and
then he went off to the gallery and they
cut the deal and you know it money
changed hands and so now we're in the
process of making this machine so this
is the first test case for this type of
machine so I'm going to show you a
little bit about it you know I I don't
know if we are here I gotta get through
but I don't know if any of you you
probably do an awful lot of sensor stuff
here I'm sure you do but I doubt if any
of you have seen the newer intel
realsense sensors you know we're sort of
I'm acquaintances with the guy who ran
basically ran the lab there and so I met
with him like a year and a half ago and
he said we're gonna do some kind of a
project at some point and so so I told
him about this project and he got really
excited about it and he goes you know
our sensor is the perfect thing for it
so what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
show you a little bit about what it is
first it's a real quick thing so you
know again the the central focus of srl
and all this repurposing of technology
of this the focus is always to preserve
the intensity and the power of the
technology and you know as a guiding
rule you know as a rule of thumb
my initial my idea was always that every
one of these machines should be able to
kill you
you know anything in one of our shows
should be capable of killing a person
that was like just the general rule of
thumb so to preserve that across
different types of presentation I mean
the gallery presentation at Marlborough
certainly preserved that because believe
me tires
truck tires Mack truck tires you saw
there are not really designed to go 200
miles an hour I mean the guy at Goodyear
said it would probably work but you know
there is a risk involved in in spinning
tires up you know there's a risk in any
kinam at any time you have that much
energy there's a risk it's you know it's
scary I mean whether it's a real risk or
perceived risk but it's really intense
to be there seeing it happen it's
intense for me to be operating it even
having like that big walking machine
operating in a gallery full of people I
mean any you know people with a drink in
their hand they fall into it I mean
there's always you know there's I mean
we exist and we we we persist in this
and we continue to get away with it
based on the fact that we manage it
carefully we manage the risk carefully
we make sure that people aren't too
close to the machines in the gallery
setting or and the shows you know
everyone's always on the lookout for for
any kind of risk but at the same time
you want to maximize the intensity of it
so we I think we've we've done pretty
good so so anyway so I was faced with
this question and the question was how
am I gonna make that you know the sort
of the the the directive of SRL of
having the intent so how is that going
to work if it's a machine that's for
display in a lobby and I was like okay
so yeah we find our okay let's see so my
idea was to just you know everyone talks
about everyone talks about machines that
are gonna like chase us down and kill us
right there's like you know there was
just that big snafu in South Korea where
there was an actual lab that was formed
strictly for developing autonomous
weapons and then once that came out
publicly everyone's like oh my god like
we can't do that you know it's like
terrible and you know and all these
people pulled out of it and so I said
you know what I think what would be cool
is to why not just like quit cut to the
chase and let's make a machine that
actually is designed to hunt people and
kill them and put it behind something
safe like a half inch bulletproof
plastic and that will be what we're
gonna do so you know the idea was to
make an arm so this is just a folded
view of the arm it's about six feet long
and it's using a it's using a drive
system using a high pressure like a
poppet valve high-pressure gas system to
launch it at this pivot the pivot and
the lower left there and you know I
adjusted the linkages so it would get a
good drive off of that so the the the
the cylinder is running at eight hundred
psi which is native pressure of co2 so
you've got basically eight hundred psi
over three inches in diameter so with no
flow losses because it's using a poppet
valve that exposes a port that's bigger
than the diet but twice the diameter of
the piston itself so you really don't
have any flow losses and so that is
going to launch that arm out at about
200 miles an hour so there's all kinds
of a little cumbersome with my all kinds
of breaking stuff that's I've designed
into here and let me get to the other
arm so this is the production drawing
for it or the I'm sorry I'm not yeah so
oh I think it's this one yeah
so that's the arm extended there and let
me find the other one here yeah so you
know this this all came up really quick
and I had to think fast right because
there was like I didn't want to miss the
sale right and so I cannot find the
drawing of it here but anyway so in
December there was a video that was kind
of online you know kind of went I guess
it went a little bit viral it was like I
don't know where it was I think maybe
was in China but there was like a albino
tiger and it was in a lexan shield and
it was a guy talking on his phone
someone's videotaping he's talking on
his phone and the tiger like sort of
snuck up behind the guy and got be eight
feet away from him and somebody he
looked up the person on the phone said
hey you know if it's a tiger behind just
getting all crazy and the guy turned
around and the second he turned around
it jumped on him the full eight foot
white tiger jumped and smashed against
the Lex and I was like wow that was
that's kind of interesting like it
really was hunting him down and stuff
like that that was exciting and I was
like yeah I want to make a machine that
does that I want to make a machine that
hunts people and attacks him and I can't
not I cannot find the other picture of
this but anyway yeah and so so anyway
that's the idea there was a there's a
there was a presentation drawing of that
I swear I put it on here but I don't see
it on here so I'm not gonna worry about
it so anyway so that's the that's the
basic idea you can see that it's got
we've got some you know here's the it's
mattered on a on a like a like a
cylinder basically go with a couple
server but pretty simple system a few
servo motors and like just Modbus
talking to talking to the software from
the sensor and you know we've got a claw
with an under actuated type claw with
and behind it we're using four four
spring for for shock absorber using
urethane springs which is common in the
tool and dye industry they don't use
steel springs they use urethane
different diameters and so that's that
that breaks when the claw hits the when
the claw hits the the lexan at 150 miles
an hour that will absorb a little bit of
that and you can see these the linkages
the linkage up there and the linkage
there those are also sliding tubes with
urethane Springs in them so that takes
away that takes a little bit of the
energy from the driving the acceleration
and it also handles a little bit of the
energy dissipates a little bit of the
energy from the deceleration and so it's
all gonna be made out of 4x4 aluminum
square bar and I've got a big five axis
CNC machine a big dmg five axis CNC
machine so we're gonna mill it out so it
looks like an alien artifact really just
which basically spars down the middle
and all milled out on the sides this is
sort of a variation on an arm that's on
the back of a MIT running machine right
now not Mark Ray Bert's machines but
it's a so it's actually we call it the
predator arm it actually it's more of a
predator leg but a prayer leg doesn't
really sound as good as a printer arm so
for practical purposes we're calling it
that and so essentially what this does
is it uses this sensor here this intel
realsense sensor which i can turn on for
you
what we're doing is we're gonna use that
and when a group of people come up to it
right now I think what we're what we've
decided we're going to be using is we're
using this because it has a skeleton
detection mode in it which is pretty
useful for what we're doing it rotates
on that yeah I'm trying to find the yeah
so if I can find them okay so here is an
example
you know and I don't really know how
many skeletons it'll detect okay so
anyway you can see if someone wants to
stand in front here gain a little bit
closer and see so those dots are like
your joints so you can see that it's
doing that in real time and we don't
know how many it can model but if we get
a couple other every every different
person is just in notated as a different
color on this but uh but the important
thing is that this it can handle
multiple subjects and it can tell where
your body is what your body is doing so
you can basically then program your
rules for it so that you know if two
people are talking and their arms are up
when their arms go down and they turn
away like they're not as soon as you see
that they're not paying attention then
you can attack so you can program you
can model sort of predator behaviors you
can see it's now now that it's found
them it's detecting them all the way
back into the all the way back into the
back of the room and so each person gets
a different color or something you know
in this they get a different color
there's another version of this that I
that we haven't been able to get to run
yet I think because the firmware on the
camera needs to be updated to the latest
firmware there's another one that then
just creates a stick figure so this is
just creating the the joints where your
pivots are so the cool thing about this
is that unlike in the past when you know
when we had to design and build all of
our own electronics at SRL what's great
about this you know you can get stuff
like this for one hundred and fifty
dollars this this sensor is one hundred
fifty bucks and like I bought the
software that's doing all this back-end
stuff for 50 bucks and like so now all
we have to do is write the the hooks
from this out to our servo motors and
out you know out in and create that
level of that level the higher level
software which is actually pretty
nothing mean it's not that hard to do so
imagine trying to do this a few years
ago you'd have to have a team of people
you'd have to have like
you know I need a million dollars or I
can't take a breath you know I mean it
would be really impossible to do but now
on a artists budget it's possible to to
create a machine that you know basically
will hunt people down and and try to get
you and so this is gonna be part of in
addition to five and believe you know
this is all was described to the client
and the clients a CEO of a huge company
he was like that's great you know that's
just a great thing someone really needs
to do this and like we're gonna put in
our lobby in like a year at big European
City and I'm like great I like that you
know like that's what I really like I
love to see you know cuz this you know
another part of the whole aspect of srl
because you know you really it's very
hard to get you know permission to to do
these kind of shows you know typically
you would think how are you gonna you
know how are you gonna be allowed to do
something that disrupt how you gonna run
a v1 in downtown San Francisco you know
like technically these things aren't
permitted how are you going to use
explosives in downtown Tokyo you know
technically you shouldn't really be able
to do that but you know part of the but
but you can't just do it and rate and
just say I'm just gonna do this and
everyone's gonna feel good about it
because they're not going to feel good
about it you're gonna get into a lot of
trouble and everyone's gonna be really
mad so I always make sure that we create
a co-conspirator network with
institutions and that's how we're able
to do these things and it seems really
impossible and it just seems you know
but the the simple fact is is that you
know people are excited about subversive
uses of things you know things that are
outside the envelope I mean you know a
lot of people you know we have a lot of
people working with us at srl some of
the same people that have been working
with us for 35 years and they're all
like you know mucky-mucks at Google X
and you know they have their fancy jobs
a lot of them but they'll when there's a
show that comes up they'll literally
take vacation time off to come and work
on the productions because
people you know it's a it's you know
it's ice there there's a certain
awareness that you know a certain
freshness that I think people who work
in the technologies for get from taking
it outside of the sphere that there that
everyone says it's supposed to be in and
actually getting something done I mean
we you know we are you know we're we've
we've kind of we've kind of turned in
you know I think we've we've done a lot
of things I think I've see I see
mirrored in other companies I mean for
instance you know like rather than you
know rather than me going to get my
doctorate in mechanical engineering or
Electrical Engineering I I came to the
realization when I was like looking
through all these factors I said you
know what all these parts just already
fit together all you have to do is like
kind of like get them close enough and
connect them all you don't need to
really know much of anything you know
you basically just need to know how to
read how to understand you know some
basic things and read up on it well you
know now really you have whole companies
that are based on that from what I
understand from a lot of people that
work at Google if you really understand
how to read scientific papers to find
the right scientific papers to read them
really understand them and really know
how to read a user manual you can get
hired that's like a very important part
of technology you know in practical
application of technology if you can do
those things we don't really care like
like I have friends who work at Google
excellent like so basically until you
get embarrassed by the old ones you can
just kind of get away with it he was
like telling me oh yeah we're in these
meetings and there's all these young
people in there that are like they've
got their degrees but they don't really
know what the old people know they don't
really know what us old ones know and he
was describing this one where you'll
only get the joke here I'm sure but he
was talking about the frequency of some
device and he was talking about some
analog device a completely analog device
that can handle you know the is a very
extreme
device and so this one guy kept going
well what's the frequency that it can
operate and Greg you know my friend Greg
goes whoa it's an analog device so
there's really no frequency to it and he
goes well I don't understand like what
frequency is it at and finally the head
guy at the table goes such-and-such he
goes uh he goes since an analog device
he goes did it's not a digital device
and he goes well what do you mean he
goes it's it's a not a digital device
and the guy goes oh and so he's made a
whole life of himself at Google
embarrassing people that don't really
have this kind of rigorous scientific
training that an older generation had
the you know people that would be
working you know people who were
professors here probably or work at SLAC
or something like that so but I think
that that's you know that's the the the
priority is if you're trying to just get
real things done you know you're
basically borrowing as much as you can
from people who have already created the
building blocks you know and that's a
more efficient model because there is so
much stuff out there and you know you
know that's uh it's how like an
organization like SRL can go from you
know from do these kind of projects and
build these kind of devices and stage
shows without really having any money
for one thing and without really you
know with with me not really having
professional training you know I was
able to leverage my just sort of
intuitive awareness of engineering and
devices to the extent that allowed it to
happen I don't really know how it
happens I don't really know how I figure
out things but everything I've ever
decided is gonna work that I built it
SRL has always worked and there's always
been people who are going that's never
gonna work you're never gonna get a
railgun
to like spray molten metal in a
controlled way five or six hundred feet
or you're never going to make a shock
wave cannon that uses like
basically like a shock tube you know and
methane and oxygen to create a shock
wave that can travel through the air
that's you know how are you gonna figure
that out and like I didn't you know I
didn't have to use like some kind of
flow dynamic program to do it I just
sort of guessed that it would work based
on the fact that I had a Mattel toy
called the sonic blast when I was 11
that worked and I was like it's so
simple what it does like you just have
to get you just have to create you know
like a jet of air traveling at a high
speed and it folds it into a toroid and
that toroid well you know it's just
guessing basically so you know it's it's
from a point of ignorance but I still it
still seems to be effective enough for
entertainment purposes and so one last
thing that I want to do because I guess
my time is getting close to up I don't
know how much more time it has but if
one really important thing I want to
show people here is we did a show on I'm
going to show you we're gonna go in the
Wayback Machine let the computer wave
hack machine but the wayback machine
that was before the Internet and this is
something that was allowed to happen on
the Stanford campus that I don't think
you would probably see much anymore and
that is that is a show with these
machines right in front of the dean's
office and back in 1987 we did a show in
front of the dean's office so this is
what you used to be able to do here but
anyway so what we did is yes there was
an international design conference at
Stanford see if this and so they just
asked us if we want to do a show and you
knows in 1987 I said I will totally do a
show in the daytime and at Stanford and
they go well the only place we can
really do this is right in front of the
dean's off is this head okay this is
what the administrators here you know
it's a it's it's the only open space
around here that we can do it
I was like sure we'll do it there and so
we just did this show like right in
front of the dean's office and it was
really extreme and then you know like I
thought oh they're gonna be really
pissed about this but in fact they
weren't they everyone was just like
acted like it was totally a normal thing
which is kind of amazing but I mean the
other thing we could do is I could
connect I could get online and I could
just download it from the interwebs on
our YouTube channel yeah does anybody
have any questions what conspiracy
theories you have a DVI output on your
HDMI output that's the problem well
we've got all kinds of outputs here do
you have a well we could just look at it
on the screen put it right over right
here and you could look at it it's not
very high we didn't have the most high
you know we're in like early beta
pre-beta SP I think this was shot it in
beta cam was before they put the SP on
it but does anybody have any questions
while we're seeing if we can do that yes
we've done that already in fact I did a
whole presentation on that and in fact
we had a competition with Rodney Brooks
at MIT for swarming machines back in
and 90 and so we I bet Rodney Brooks me
and my group of people Raymond Drury
Jonathan Levine and I forget who else
but we bet I bet Rodney Brooks that we
could get our AI life swarming machines
to work before he could he goes well
we'll see and so in fact and so we kept
calming so she was working yet I said
would you get yours working as well no
not yet
and so I called him up and I said we've
got ours working and so there were a
group of his grad students that were out
in San Francisco and they they came over
and we showed them working and they said
yours worked before ours so so anyway so
that's that is where the swarmers and
basically it was all homemade they were
about as big as a 55-gallon drum and
about that tall we made five of them and
so what they ran is very simple this is
1990 so they had infrared sensors and a
rotating mirror you know that was they
didn't work outside they didn't work in
a building with bright light and so
basically what they would do is they
would look for each other when they
would identify which one of the five it
was and then they would move towards
each other and when they got close to
close they would move away from each
other and so what you know like a
typical simple a life program like that
you can hit that let go so basically
what it would do is it would uh you know
look it they would take make these kind
of interesting patterns of movement like
chasing each other around and eventually
they get stuck in a corner because they
weren't detecting anything in the real
world except each other but so yeah so
this is in front of dean's office that's
just a simple walking machine run by a
PLC that's the original one that was
installed by Stanford doctorate student
Phil Paul back in 86 87
so this was what was considered normal
on campus in 1987 this is just a normal
afternoon at Stanford nothing unusual
you know free for anybody to see
that's the flippy box that is like if
you read too much you start to get ideas
about books that are different from what
you should be getting and so it's not I
don't hear the sound now but that's okay
so that's another crazy thing up Square
wheel car attacking another machine and
that's it it was like about 7 or 8
minutes long I think so anyway so I just
thought that that would be thank you
everyone would be interested to know
that that was just considered a normal
thing I don't think you would be able to
probably do that anymore but uh you know
then again I'm always surprised by what
people allow you to do I mean you know
but that you know I just I just think
that from in in in terms of like being a
technical person and being an engineer
you know looking forward into the future
I like to think that we are sort of
prefiguring some possibilities and one
of those I think it's really important
that I just wanted to make sure I
brought up was that you know everyone
talks about oh yeah you know if you've
got an education and you've got all
these skills you'll always have a job
but you know what if there are no jobs I
mean at a certain point there just are
gonna be a lot fewer jobs there's
certain point there's the point there's
you reach a peak and technology stops
creating jobs and there's been many
books written about that and technology
starts taking away jobs and so you have
to create new jobs and so what I like to
think is that SRL is a template for a
future where there may not be any jobs
but you know people are not you know I
don't think you're really human
unless you have a purpose and so having
a purpose now means your purpose is tied
in with the latest technology I mean it
should if you really want to feel the
real power of like what it means to be
human
you've got to tie your life to
technology and you've got to really be
an engineer if you want to feel real
satisfaction but you also have to have
something to do with it and I think that
you know a future where you know we
revert back to the medieval model of
like the ultra gazillionaire soon-to-be
trillionaire is out there will just be
bleeding sweating money and so if you
want to absorb any of the tears of you
know a sweat that's falling off of them
you get you're gonna have to develop you
know a way to use your training use your
skills use your interests and to create
you know you're gonna have to say this
is a job this is an important thing and
you're gonna have to get in on the on
the ground floor and and I think that
that's you know being involved in a
creative expression of the arts a
creative expression of your engineering
skills is a good way to do it because
you know it's a good way to have human
dignity and to have a reason to be doing
what you're doing and and I also just
think that it's uh you know it's it's
the way of the future and you know we're
trying to we're trying to show how it
works with with you know I'm gonna be
trying to do more of these sort of art
project type things and trying to sell
them I mean partly just to make an
income stream because it gets very
expensive when you're working outside of
an institution and you have to pay for
everything yourself and you don't have a
trust fund you have to figure out
creative ways of financing and so I need
additional means of financing and so
that's one of the reasons where I kind
of took this path but in the process of
doing it you know it's it's I've really
a lot of things that I've thought about
over the years
I realize that that there you know that
there could come to fruition so I'm
gonna take some more questions I've
talked enough I'm tired of talking about
I could be the only expert on srl out
there I've got two more here though
there's something about that subversion
in the dignity about sort of taking the
taking the piss out of the technology
and and creating it into something
that's fun that maintains that it's
really true there is what if there's no
what if there what if there's a
diminishing number of practical reasons
to even do anything you know then what
happens I mean right now there's a
million you know we need some what we
need engineers to do this but everyone
talks about the shortage of Engineers to
to create their products but what at a
certain point what happens is if if so
much of that stuff becomes automated and
done by nonhumans that there's no
baseline to compare subversion to you
know then like what's subversive then is
are the Machine subversive they're doing
everything or are the are the people
that you know what the subversive thing
would probably be that if you're still
willing to do something basically on
spec you know if you're doing it because
you love to do it basically there's a
beauty in the destruction that we
created I feel well not for a mass
consumption along those lines is you're
saying how the guess we're tell them in
kind of works for the entertainment
purposes but is like is this a moral
imperative for you like I don't want it
to be like a little pretty and look
precise or like driving me or is it just
like it works for me and you know people
like this and it's good but it could be
another way well you know I'm sort of
the I'm of the opinion that is expressed
in for instance a book like war in the
age of intelligent machines where who's
directing who you know I don't know if
you ever read that book it's a book by
Manuel DeLand are very important
sort of treatise on like what our role
is as humans in relation to the machines
or technology we're building right and
he sort of turns it on its head and sort
of makes a bunch of you know interesting
points about it but you know I think
that for me it's all the important thing
has always been trying to preserve the
intensity and the ferocity of technology
and so I see where some people see a
bottling machine I see some terrifying
nightmare you know that could be made
with that bottling machine you know with
all the parts for it and like that to me
is the truest expression of like what
the the purest expression of what is
going on there like you can see you know
there's all the excitement of a you know
of a process machine there's like
something coming in on one end and then
there's the process and then there's the
end result and so that's beautiful you
know but why does it have to why can't
it just go from why can't it just start
from something create something and then
destroy it at the end that's a process
to but but having it having it a process
which is destructive preserve some
important things about a machine it
preserves the idea that it's more has
more power more speed than a human
because it can do something that a human
couldn't do it but it becomes it becomes
superhuman and so by having it do
something destructive and really intense
like that that's the easiest way to
prove to make a proof for the superhuman
powers of of a servomechanism
or a device that projects are you know
power somehow through technology and so
so I like to preserve those things in
the machines that's why like I said the
the baseline is always that you have to
you have to when you're confronted with
an SRL machine it has to be something
that's scary and intimidating and
physically empower you know physically
threatening
so let's take the microphone away then
you can tell the truth okay about what
okay this is a suspension of disbelief
that all those things that look like
Mike's hanging seal are not microphones
okay good there dr. dog okay well this
was all well you won't believe
[Applause]
you